one thing we don't have is any official
statistics that showed the coronavirus
toll by demographic but in some
communities the pandemic appears to be
disproportionately affecting people of
color our national correspondent Jericka
Duncan has been looking into this jurika
good morning we heard David beg no
report earlier today that he observed
mostly black men in the ICU in the
hospital where he was very interesting
finding there what have you found well
it's no secret Tony that African
Americans have a higher rate of things
like diabetes asthma hypertension those
underlying conditions that we talked
about that have led to the deaths of
people with corona virus and because of
that one local health commissioner who
called racism a public health issue says
she's taking the lead by collecting
important information that she says
could help save lives you know we're in
the middle of the storm right now we
need as much data as possible right now
we're flying blind Milwaukee health
commissioner jeanette Kowalik is
overseeing roughly a million residents
in Milwaukee County of the 40 people who
have died so far because of the corona
virus in your county what percentage of
those people are black right now it's
still about 80 percent african-americans
make up 26% of the population correct
right now the CDC is not collecting data
on the race of those who have tested
positive or died from corona virus and
important to actually document the race
of the people who are infected and dying
everyone will be affected by this but
there are some communities and
populations are going to be affected
even more significantly dr. you che
Blackstock is founder and CEO of
advancing health equity in New York City
the reason why we need to really discuss
this issue and to collect the racial and
ethnic demographic data on who is tested
who has the disease and on who's dying
from it so that we can properly allocate
healthcare resources equitably to the
communities that need it dr. Blackstock
also works part-time at urgent care
facilities in Brooklyn can you describe
the makeup of the people in your waiting
room right now
more black and brown and immigrant
patients that are seeking care a lot of
these patients are essential workers one
of them are service workers
she says testing is still not readily
available
how many koban 19 tests are you all able
to give each day we are instructed that
we probably should not test more than 1
in 10 patients so 10% no more than 10%
of the people that come through there
every day our criteria is really
focusing on the highest risk patients
CBS News contributor Abram X kandi is
also director of the anti-racist Policy
Center at American University if we
don't have an awareness right now of
racial disparities you can't right now
figure out what's causing those racial
disparities what policies or even lack
thereof and we can't change it right now
in the moment when people are dying and
being infected and according to a new
report by WBEZ
public radio in Chicago an analysis of
the county found that 70% of people in
Chicago who have passed away because of
coronavirus are black and you're talking
about nearly 300 deaths right now in the
whole state of Illinois because of
coronavirus but definitely important
information when you look at how we
track other diseases other viruses and
this being a pandemic I'm sure there are
a lot of people that are hungry for that
information right now I'll say Jericka
this is such an important story we have
we've heard this saying all the time
knowledge is power and all of your
experts seem to say that you need more
information to know exactly what you're
dealing with and how we need to fight it
so glad that you were bringing rays
exactly thank you very much to Rica
Duncan reporting from her home to